hey there welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend a podcast
that tries to build bridges to a better
world
i don't know
that's new i needed to say something and
i said that and it's just not true i
know we're building nothing
this is the damn buster
[Laughter]
we're the dynamite at the base of a very
big dam
and there's a there's a whole
civilization beneath us that will be
flooded
once this podcast airs um
joined as always by uh sona mafsession
hey sonya hi and uh of course matt
gourley hey by the way dambusters is
what we call it when my newborn daughter
has a poop that explodes out the back of
her diaper that's terrific
that's uh that's great
oh man that's great these are some good
poops that's good that's good we're
building a bridge yeah yeah to a better
world yes
i don't know why i thought if if if one
of those billionaires said hey conan do
you want to go to space would you do it
would i go to space yeah no i'm very
happy with earth okay i'm very happy
with earth i have never had any desire
and i have lots of friends that would
say oh my god i would love it to go into
space or
um i have a friend that wants to be on
one of those mars missions where you're
you're pretty much assured you're never
coming back oh i like it here on earth i
do too this is where i was
millions of years of evolution
i'd go i'd go as long as i didn't have
to go with all the weirdos that are the
first ones to go up there like that you
would you would definitely go yeah i
think if it were proven safe for oh for
god's sake you can't you can't it's not
uh
so you'd go as long as it's 100 safe no
i didn't say that i said proven
safe like
you know give it a few years and then
all the weird tech moguls aren't going
up there i don't want to be dying with
those people
you kidding your your estate can sue
them you want to be on the one with
basos that so this is like suicide by
orbit yeah so my family gets insurance
claims
they get to call the basos estate and
say hey
it's because
your husband pushed the blue button
instead of the green button
that my husband didn't make it so and
they're like fine whatever here's a
billion dollars
don't call again and you're in the clear
i would certainly throw up though just
from the motion of it i think maybe not
they probably worked it out it probably
just feels like a tesla accelerating
i'm sure that's exactly what it feels
like
you know um no i i have no desire sona
do you want to go into space um i i
would do one of those missions where the
you go up you're like hey earth and then
you come right back down i just want to
do like the tower of terror version
yeah you want to go on a spaceship that
goes 300 feet into the air and then
lands gently and they open the doors and
they serve you pizza right that's what
you want and say like you went to space
trust us trust us
oh boy did you go to space
really because i was felt like i just
went up 300 feet yeah it's just like at
the tip of mount baldy
[Laughter]
um
[Laughter]
no i'm not going to space i have no
interest i'm tired of people asking me
please go to space please leave earth
please
please get out how do you think i want
to go to space
you don't even want to go you just are
trying to lure me
into going i want you because you can
have earth i need to get away yeah okay
all right
you